the National Geographic Channel
celebrates the dog whispers 100th
episode with a dog on off the bone
partay and the guest list includes all
the stars of the show
Cesar Millan the owners he's helped
train and the dogs he rehabilitated the
toughest cases as always the the fearful
cases you know they wanted faced long
pier 14 like Luna and definitely my
toughest case because she was absolutely
petrified of pretty much everything my
dog my dog that doesn't seem to enjoy
being a dog Gavin was tough but it was
just a matter of time Gavin to me
represents the true American dog
Gavin served the country went to Iraq
when he came back and they wanted to
retire him he was not able to retire
happy I'll say he's suffering from
post-traumatic stress syndrome Gavin was
afraid of thunderstorm firecrackers
sound whatever we're surrounded by
gunshots and sound you can change the
physiology in so many ways and you
change the physiology you change the
mind or you change the Mon you change
the body whatever it takes whatever it
takes this way right now we are changed
inches mine through the water the water
you can't help himself just to be
relaxed no checking no check that's what
dogs do they transform people see the
influence that make you feel more
complete
[Music]
all new episodes of The Dog Whisperer
every Friday night at nine home on Nat
Geo
[Music]